there's a lot of attention being paid in
the media these days to the both
creative and therapeutic potential of
altered states of consciousness I'm
talking about the euphoric and poetic
reveries occasioned by certain molecules
and compounds known as psychedelics as
well as cannabis and so it's really
interesting and trying to make sense of
these altered states you know some
people refer to them as mythopoetic
trance states states of consciousness in
which you experience an absolute unmixed
attention a form of Prayer a feeling of
the divine feeling of the sublime a kind
of OPA 'td adjacency which you're
cracked open and you can see the light
and so why does so much magic how do we
make sense of these enchanted states
what do they tell us about the nature of
how we perceive reality and I think a
great analogy for an altered state is
dreaming human beings go to sleep every
night occasionally they have these vivid
vivid dreams that they can remember and
sometimes dreams can be sublime and
adventuring and full of joy and Wonder
and reverie as you fly and you live out
all kinds of fantasies the laws of
physics no longer apply you are a mind
and flight dreams are glimpses to the
potential of the human imagination but
sometimes dreams become nightmares
sometimes the emotions of fear and dread
can pollute the dream can hijack the
dream can disrupt the dream
in states of consciousness that are
unique altered states of consciousness
are very similar people talk about
infinite resonance with set and setting
is the most crucial variables to
determine the outcome of the experience
whether it would be positive or negative
David Lentz and goes further he says if
you think of what human consciousness is
human consciousness is a collaboration
between subject and object we are always
a mixture of our own expectations and
personality traits right and
predispositions and the environment that
surrounds us with its contextual cues
and its way of suggesting a certain kind
of behavior or reality we window dress
reality and we become the window
dressing so to speak and so when we are
in a highly suggestible state an altered
state is characterized by high
suggestibility by infinite resonance
with whatever signals are coming in both
from within and from without then it
becomes infinitely important to curate
your set and setting so when you're
entering into an altered state of
consciousness you should be you should
pre construct the environment you should
think judiciously about the space and
the signals that the space broadcasts
when you're gonna be in that highly
suggestible and open state of
consciousness and if you do pre
construct and program the set and
setting then an altered state experience
can be very much akin to a waking dream
and in your pre-planning of creating an
environment that is safe and imaginative
and beautiful and sublime then the
environment is broadcasting that
particular vibe into the dream so you're
less likely to have a nightmare during
this waking dream it's very much like
the film Inception right that Chris
Nolan films in which Leonardo DiCaprio
is like a dream hacker and he's
explaining to people that like when
you're in a when you're in a dream state
if something happens in the default
world
it literally pollutes your dream state
so example like if you're in the in the
real world when you're dreaming you're
in the real world and somebody sprays
water in your face then in your dream
it'll start raining so to speak and I
think altered states are very similar
the sentence setting becomes the signal
that permeates the flavor of the dream
so the waking dream becomes something
there's incredible
malleable the potential here is huge for
psychotherapy because means that you can
create the conditions that will inform a
particular kind of psychological
experience that that within the person's
consciousness so you can pre construct
the kind of experience that they're more
likely to have through your creative and
linguistic choices which means that we
become authors of our dreams whose
outcomes then of course spill over into
our wake are waking States it's the
reason that when people have mystical
experiences that are positive they leave
lasting positive cognitive benefits you
know ad infinitum so yeah I think
there's a lot to explore here in terms
of the potential of altered states of
consciousness for human creativity for
human flourishing you could think of
them ultimately as is a kind of open
heart surgery for the mind I think we
can get really creative and really
imaginative and in combination with
altered states of consciousness sensory
deprivation tanks augmented and virtual
reality experiences we can really
unleash the human soul to landscapes and
soundscapes & dreamscapes beyond our
imagination this is our potential to
move into our own imaginations to
literally make our dreams come true and
in the words of Willy Wonka never forget
we are the music makers and we are the
dreamers of dreams
[Music]